nous sommes devant le parc des expos de
la porte de versailles à paris
coville oblige plus aucun salon a lieu
dans ce complexe qui est transformé en
parti depuis le 5 mai dernier en
vaccinodromes de quoi compléter le
dispositif des 27 centres de vaccination
déjà ouvertes dans la capitale
l'objectif affiché par la ville de paris
est d'atteindre danse vaccinodromes les
20000 injection par semaine ici comme
ailleurs tout le monde ou presque peut
se faire vacciner toutes les personnes
de 50 ans et plus bien entendu est en
réalité depuis le 12 mai dernier
n'importe quelle personne âgée de plus
de 18 ans sous réserve de disponibilité
des doses de la veille pour le lendemain
d'ailleurs le gouvernement songe à lever
cette restriction avant la date du 15
juin prévu initialement
de quoi accélérer encore la campagne
vaccinale sauf qu'une partie de la
population elles tardent à s'immuniser
selon le site qu'ovide tracker 21 % des
plus de 75 ans n'ont encore reçu aucune
dose et plus de 15% supplémentaires
attendent encore la seconde injection
le ministère de la santé a pourtant
indiqué avoir lancé une campagne
d'appels de l'assurance maladie à
destination de ces populations est mis
en place un numéro coupe-file dédié
reste que près de quatre français sur
dix de plus de 75 ans ne sont
aujourd'hui pas ou insuffisamment
protégée soit plus de deux millions et
demi de personnes
bien évidemment les facteurs sont
multiples d'abord il y à la mobilité
si la vaccination dans les ehpad a bien
fonctionné il est plus que compliquée de
toucher les personnes isolées voire
refuse pour qui internet reste un
mystère et dont l'état de santé ne
permet tout simplement pas de se
déplacer dans un centre de vaccination
en gros des personnes qui n'ont pas
accès aux vaccins
d'autant que ce dernier souffre de
conditions de conservation draconiennes
et qu'il est donc difficilement
transportable jusqu'au patient ce qui
est le cas avec pfizer
le vaccin le plus administrer
aujourd'hui qui nécessite deux doses
donc deux déplacements là où d'autres
ces roms comme le johnson and johnson
n'en retenir qu'un seul
et puis il y a la motivation les plus de
75 ans sont les français les moins
actifs et les moins mobiles et donc par
conséquent ceux pour qui le passeport
vaccinale n'a que peu d'utilité
sans compter bien sûr la méfiance
vis-à-vis
depuis les antilles va ou ce qu'ils
n'ont tout simplement pas peur du virus
en bref l'isolément une logistique
pénalisante et un manque d'intérêt
semble faire stagner la vaccination chez
cette tranche d'âge pourtant la plus
vulnérables protéger en priorité les
plus fragiles était au coeur de la
stratégie sanitaire du gouvernement
force est de constater que l'objectif
n'est pas encore remplies